hi everybody
I'm Lyle standing in New York City boob
capital of North America looking for
great New York boobs scuse me pardon me
miss hi can I talk to you for one second
pardon me can I talk to you from my TV
show please don't run boy she had some
sweet New York boobs
guys I'm I'll and you have great New
York boobs hi what's your name
Jeannie you have great New York boobs
fantastic
this is Joe Rogan from NBC's Fear Factor
can I tell you something you have great
New York boobs are we talking c-cups
because perhaps well I drink from those
C cups any day fabulous you rest on my
arm like an egg
these are some of the best boobs you can
see in the city
Moravsky please down run they're busy
and this is Joe Rogan from NBC's Fear
Factor can I tell you something
you have great New York boobs you have
fabulous genetics that's all
you helped make a great set of New York
boobs
[Music]